now we're going to talk about the two
forms of the inductor equation and get
familiar with these things
i'm going to do some examples to show
you how the inductor equations work so
we know that the inductor equation is
the voltage across an inductor
is
a factor called l the inductance times d
i
dt
so the voltage is proportional to the
slope or the rate of change of current
let me do a quick review of the two
letters that are used as variables for
inductors when we have a resistor
we have we have a we call it an r and
it's in units of ohms and that's named
after
ohm himself and when we have a capacitor
the units are c for capacitance and f
for faraday
ferrad
that's named after michael faraday
and for the inductor we have two other
letters we use l
and h
and l is the name of the component and
that's named after lens heinrich lens
and he did some research in induction
and the unit is named after henry
and so that's the corresponding r c and
l
are the names of the components and ohms
ferrets and henries are the units
okay let's get back to our inductor
there's another form of the inductor
equation where we write it in terms of
just i in terms of v
and to get to that point we need to get
rid of this derivative here so what we
what i'm going to do is take the
integral of both sides of this equation
so we take the integral of v
with respect to time
and that equals l
times
take the integral of
d i
dt
with respect to time
and these two terms
go away and have the integral of d i
the antiderivative of d i is is what
what function has a derivative of d i
and that would be just i
so let me flip this all around here now
i'm going to write i
on the left side
equals 1 over l
times the integral
of v
dt
now we always put limits on this
integral so
the limits in this case our time is goes
from minus infinity
till some time now
and this tells us that the
the current through an inductor depends
on the voltage across that inductor for
the entire life all the way back to time
equals minus infinity
and
that's not so convenient we don't want
to track this the inductor's voltage
back that far in time so what we'll do
instead is we'll we'll say let's say at
t equals zero
that we know the volt that we know the
current that we know some
we know some i of zero
and then we can change the limits on our
our integral here
to be zero on the bottom
one over l
integral from time is zero
until now time t big t
of
v of t
times dt
in order to account for everything
that's happened before time equals zero
we'll just say what was the current at
time equals zero so that's i
of zero
and i'll do one more little change i i i
i want this variable up here to be small
t
and that means i have to replace this t
inside here with some other symbol
as a dummy variable and so now i'm going
to get i of t little t
1 over l
integral from 0 to little t
of v
d let's just call it tau
plus
i
of zero
so this is the integral form
there's the integral form of the
inductor equation and here is the
derivative form
and we'll use both these what i'm going
to do now is we're going to do an
exercise where we use this one down here
so in our circuit we have a voltage
source
with a time pattern voltage in it
and
we have a current going through this
thing and we want to find out what's
this current
so we're connected to a inductor it's a
10 millihenry inductor
and the voltage waveform is it starts at
zero at time equals zero
the the voltage goes up to two volts
then after two milliseconds it goes to
minus two volts
after two more milliseconds it goes to
plus two volts and on and on
so we know v of t and what we're going
to figure out is what's what's i through
the in the inductor and to do that we're
going to use our
our inductor equation here the integral
form of the inductor equation
so i actually need some room on the
screen here so let me take a second and
clean out some stuff
okay we're ready to go
so let's look at what's going on here
before time equals zero so then the
before state we're going to make an
assumption we're going to assume that i
is zero
a long time ago and if we look at our
chart here it says that v is 0 as well
and if i take this fact and i look at
this equation right here if v is 0
l is some positive number
so we can say that so then we know that
di
dt
equals zero so this circuit is pretty
much doing nothing
before this waveform starts working
over here i'm going to make a little
time chart
of what what we discover
that's time and this will be
current here
so before zero before time is zero
we can say that the current is zero now
we plotted in part of our our curve
okay now something happens now the
voltage book goes up to 2 volts and
we're going to use this equation the
integral form of the the inductor
equation to figure out what happens to i
of t
now that voltage has changed
so we can say that i
equals 1 over l
times the integral
from 0 times 0 is our starting point
here
to t
sometime t
of
v of t now v in this little region of
time here
is 2 volts
plus 2
times d tau
plus
i zero and we decided i zero was the
current that it started at right there i
zero is zero
let's keep working on this we can say
that i
equals 1 over
10 millihenries
times the 2 comes out of the integral
and now it's the integral from 0 to t
of d tau
the 0 goes away
that equals
2 over 10 millihenries
times what what's this integral evaluate
to it evaluates to t
integral of d tau between 0 and t
is t minus 0
or just plain t
so looking at this i see that i
equals a constant times t and that's the
equation of a line
that's the equation of a line if i plot
it on t and i
so
2 over 10 millihenries is the slope
and to plot that line what i need is two
points on the line i know one of the
points already i know one of the points
is going to be right there at 0 0.
what is the current at the end of this
pulse here so at 2 milliseconds let's
figure out what the current is and that
equals
at two milliseconds it's
two times
two milliseconds
divided by
ten
millihenries
the millies cancel themselves out and i
get 4 over 10 or
0.4
what amperes
so at 2 milliseconds
the value of the current is
0.4
amperes and i can draw a straight line
between there
so now we have the value of the current
during this first
excursion this first part of the voltage
waveform
now we're going to switch again now we
have a new i zero let's let's go to a
new point here
let's go to a new point at now we have i
i zero equals
0.4
and we have
v
equals what
now it goes to minus 2 volts
minus 2 volts
so let's use our inductor equation one
more time
with these
with these initial conditions
that tells us i equals
1 over l
integral
from what's the new point
2 milliseconds
to
t and v of t after two milliseconds is
minus two volts
minus two
d tau
plus
now we have a starting current our
starting current was
0.4 amps
0.4
amps
and let's continue on here let's uh
maybe you can squeeze it in here
i equals
1 over 10
millihenries
times minus 2
times the integral
the integral from
2 milliseconds
to t
of d tau
plus 0.4
i equals
minus 2 over 10 millis
times what is this
it's again it's t
minus
t minus
2 milliseconds
plus
0.4
and again we have the equation of a line
this is the equation of a line i
there's a constant times t
there's a
co and followed by a constant
and this is basically a sloping line it
has a negative slope and the net and the
slope is negative 2 over 10 millis which
is just the opposite of what we had over
here
we had 2 over 10 millihenries
so it's the same
looking kind of line so let me mark out
here
here's four milliseconds
and it's going to be a line that looks
like this
so the current is going to ramp up it's
going to turn around and ramp straight
back down
because the the slope up and the time up
is the same as the slope down and the
time down just with a negative slope
so there's an example of the inductor
equation in action